bienvenue dans ce pack spécial était
comme c'est l'été on va parler beaucoup
de sport venir évidemment sur l'euro de
football on parlera de golf on parlera
aussi beaucoup de stylisme et nous avons
dans le choix et la chance d'avoir
arnaud courtier avec tous qui est le
directeur général de la fédération
française de cyclisme
il ya un grand événement qui aura lieu
au mois d'octobre au vélodrome on va en
reparler avec vous ce sont les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste à kick succèdent aux championnats
du monde qui avait eu lieu
si chez vous absolument et championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste qui
auront lieu du 19 au 23 octobre 2016 au
vélodrome nationale fort du succès des
championnats du monde qui se sont
déroulés en février dernier nous avons
décidé d'y retourner une opportunité de
calendrier s'est présentée on a donc
saisi cette opportunité avec l'union
européenne de cyclisme et on va
organiser de nouveau une grande fête
pour les fans de cyclisme sur piste à
51,10 et n'ose y étions avec
jean-charles notamment et c'est vrai que
c'est un spectacle absolument c'était
extraordinaire
époustouflant comme spectacle comme
ferveur comme comme suspense
c'est la première fois de ma vie que
j'ai les pieds dans un vélodrome et que
j'assistais à ça il était mais carrément
bluffé et scotché par intérêt d'où je
reviendrai que le plaisir à refaire la
joie ni éditeurs on parlera peut-être un
petit conseil de lecture pour l'été
bagarre je m'appelle requiem et je te
voilà je suppose que je t'emmerde parce
que si j'ai bien compris et stanislas
petro ce qui est train adorateurs de
frédéric dard donc à la sécurité ont
déjà tué plus tôt je t'emmerde que je
t'aime mais voilà mais après on peut le
prendre comme vous on en parle à un
total à florence mercadé bonjour
l'avocat patrick ouart 2 versailles et
six pistes
oui ça m'arrive ça m'arrive jamais
assisté à deux courses vous avez tort
oui c'est une bonne occasion de venir 9
octobre puis il fait à peu près aussi
choc ici ouais mais oui mais au moins il
ya des gens qui se dépensent c'était
fade mon sens bonjour je voulais être
professeur à l'université de saint
quentin versailles et et se déniche
travaillent toute l'année
oui bien sûr enfin contre certains ou
presque oui oui moi tout est de votre
sport favori ce à quoi on le droit à
pratiquer mon sport favori sont enfin
mes sports favoris ce sont les sports de
montagne et le cyclisme en montagne fin
ccc comme dit l'autre une tuerie jeu et
donc fins et c'est un cauchemar
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé alors et je n'ai
pas fait que du vélo de descente parce
qu'il ya pour les touristes et les
centres on les emmène en eau en minibus
à idc nourrissent pas parce que ces deux
types qui force avait fait aimer le vélo
de montée est aussi redoutable et ben
justement pas un mot peut-être puisque
c'est un des événements de l'été le tour
de france quand même qui est un d un des
spectacles les plus populaires qui
dresse d'abord c'est gratuit c'est un
progrès très exactement avec là aussi un
suspense est absolument avec soi même et
avec des performances incroyables quand
vous expliquer justement ce succès le
succès qui ne se dément jamais du temps
d'enfin il ya des affaires on parle
parfois de dopage il dit il ya eu des
périodes un peu plus noir et malgré ça
le succès est toujours au rendez vous je
crois que les raisons sont assez simples
en fin de compte le cyclisme est un
sport que tout le monde peut pratiquer
twain c'est faire du mend a tous fait du
héros
que ce soit pour se promener pour faire
les courses pour faire un peu de
compétition nous du vélo en famille dont
tout le monde sait ce que c'est que
l'effort de pédaler pendant de longues
heures si on n'a jamais fait on imagine
très très bien et vous l'avez dit
populaire parce que gratuit le public
est présent sur les différentes étapes
au bord de la route et le succès ne se
dément pas au fil des ans
je ne vois aucune raison pour que le le
le tour ne soit plus grands succès il
l'est et d'année en année il l'est
surtout au niveau international c'est
aussi l'image de la france ces voix là
parce que alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
aussi des champions enfin venu
d'amérique ce qui était assez nouveau un
moment mais c'est vrai que le monde
entier regarde ça et en même temps je le
disais l'autre jour dans l'équipe
quelqu'un qui disait bailly noé est
irremplaçable c'est énorme à saveur de
tour de france parce que vous foncez le
dernier français à avoir gagné le tour
de france et on attend toujours un peu
trop ce que c'est c'est eh c'est vrai
que la popularité giacomino boule d'or
même à plus de 80 euros
il est toujours sur le tour c'est assez
incroyable quand on les voir leur
popularité et restent immenses et il
suffit d'être sur le tour et de les
croiser les acquisitions pour voir
effectivement combien les genres est fan
de ces grands champions mais ce sont des
grands champions et après ils sont
irremplaçables jusqu'au jour où ils
seront prêts
on tôt ou tard et je crois plutôt que ce
qu'on peut le croire a condamné il ya
des ya des athlètes très performant qui
sont là donc on va pouvoir 80 tout petit
peu d'attentes encore mais ça arrive une
victoire française
vous êtes fasciné par la dotant de
france c'est carrément génial mais il ya
la caravane aussi il est à dire ça c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire 7
ce défilé je crois qu'il ya deux cent
200 véhicules qui passaient thématisé
avait avec des des gens qui balancent
des gadgets qui sont une animation de la
musique
j'étais extrêmement amusant à voir les
camions et camionnettes sociaux se sont
bien foutus
il ya une atmosphère de fête en
permanence sur le tour quelles que
soient les étapes quel que soit des
choses et c'est vraiment extraordinaire
et puis c'est vrai ce que vous disiez
moi je me souviens un jour j'étais un
j'étais en chine et j'ai vu une étape il
y avait un truc sur la télévision
chinoise sur le tour de france et sur
saint maixent l'école se connaître que
500 l'école et qui connaît qui connaît
sa maixent l'école en chine
la visite d'une voie là blessés
uniquement les grâce au tour de france
que des chinois ont pu entendre parler
sa puissance et extraordinaires comme
comme vitrine de la france dans le monde
entier comme ça soit sa fascinante à 101
voilà le tour de faussaires et sow la
fédération française de cyclisme et
qu'elle est quel est son rôle sur le
tour bien sûr ces vaisseaux qui organise
le tour
et vraiment d'une manière extraordinaire
la fédération est présent parce que la
fédération représente la loi du sport et
les arbitres les commissaires sur le
tour sont des serres fédéraux absolument
la fédération encore la fédération
toujours à résoudre sur le tour
absolument le tour qui vous l'avez dit
c'est le bon mot une fête c'est une fête
est effectivement le tour fait voyager
pas que les étrangers a même des
français chez eux qui à travers le tour
devant leur télé voit ses paysages on
passe dans des endroits qui ont
absolument somptueux grâce aux moyens
techniques aujourd'hui donc la
télévision la télévision la lingerie en
direct très longuement enfin le
pratiquement la totalité des étapes donc
exactement
donc c'est vrai qu'on voit ouvriers en
même temps et c'est vrai que c'est
bénéfique
alors revenons sur sur ces championnats
d'europe de deux sit in sur piste alors
là c'est vraiment la fédération qui leur
réalisme poussé le comment ça c'est la
fédération comme tous les événements
internationaux ou européens ou mondiaux
ils sont la propriété soit de l'union
européenne de l'union cycliste
internationale il y à des candidatures
pour recevoir les événements donc nous
avons fait acte de candidature
le championnat nous a été attribuée à
partir de là selon un cahier des charges
bien précis c'est nous qui organisons de
a à z
alors il faut être très clair on
organise pas seul dans le sens où il ya
une véritable collaboration avec les
équipes fédérales avec les équipes du
vélodrome nationale et celle
particulièrement de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et encore plus
précisément de la ville de montilly
bretonneux qui nous accompagne sur tous
les aspects de logistique et technique
mais c'est bien une organisation à 100%
fédération française de cyclisme
alors la fédération française de la
société euro win
donc il ya des liens très très très très
fort entre entre vous et le vélodrome et
il ya eu le succès justement de ces
championnats du monde qui était le
premier grand événement cycliste ac qui
était organisé sur cette danse vélodrome
non c'était le premier grand événement
le vélodrome ont ouvert en janvier 2014
y avait une inauguration avec un match
france angleterre est juste un an après
cette ouverture on accueilli les
championnats du monde qui se sont
déroulés pendant cinq jours à guichet
fermé ce qui était déjà le
premier succès et puis eux
je crois que le public a joué son rôle
puisque nos français ont performé on a
fait cinq médailles d'or pendant
s'échappe une bonne humeur avec nos
athlètes et évidemment en trop dans
certains qui habitent ici parce qu'ils
sont français
car vis évidemment qui habitent ici
c'est ce qui est merveilleux pour nous
aussi salarié de la fédération c'est que
en étant installé dans le vélodrome on
les côtoie quotidiennement donc il ya
des liens là aussi qu'ils se créent et
là on essaye de leur préparer les
championnats d'europe le mieux possible
sur mesure pour qu'il puisse au retour
des jeux olympiques venir ouvrir your
are you humble il y aura rien avant
qu'hoarau est donc ils arrivent tous de
rio et là aussi alors ça se déroule sur
5 jours aussi cinq jours les championnes
d'europe cinq jours du mercredi au
dimanche avec des épreuves différentes
tous les jours donc il ya du spectacle
tous les jours si on peut pas vivre un
samedi on peut venir à mercredi
il ya plus de finale vers la fin certes
mais il ya vraiment un spectacle de
qualité tous les jours quelles sont les
grandes grandes épreuves de cyclisme sur
piste
après ça dépend des goûts de chacun non
poursuite il ya la poursuite
individuelle par équipes la vitesse le
kirin le minium voilà il ya pas mal de
pas mal de disciplines et conçoit
experts ont néophytes c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure dans le vélodrome
on est vraiment dans un chaudron on a le
spectacle sous les yeux la majorité des
disciplines se comprennent plutôt
facilement
et puis il ya des speakers il ya des
vidéos explicatives donc même si on n'y
connaît pas grand chose on peut venir on
comprendra tout est expliqué dans le
programme officiel aussi les règles
enfin tout tout tout ce qu'on a à savoir
donc on soit connaisseur ou qu'on soit
néophyte
on peut venir assister aux championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste et puis
il ya un truc qui est extraordinaire
c'est que ce sera la même chose en tout
cas pour le championnat du monde c'est
que au milieu du vélodrome il ya toutes
les équipes techniques et où on voit on
voit tout ce qui se passe rien il ya le
spectacle sur la piste mais il ya au
milieu elle après l'été on peut faire
masser ou elle ait commencé à serrer les
rangs des foires vialas pis on voit
c'est extraordinaire d'avoir être cette
vision d'impressionnantes une petite
souris de balader dans tous les autres
sports on voit pas cette partie cachée
exactement pour une fois on va se voir
la partie c'est effectivement pour on
peut dire les vestiaires sont on me dira
que les mecs quoi ils sont là la presse
est d'installer aussi dans la centrale
dont il ya il ya un spectacle permanent
et aux championnats d'europe on renoue
avec une tradition que les fans de
cyclisme adore c'est à dire qu'il y aura
aussi des dîners en centre piste un
hacker chefs d'entreprise qui ont envie
de faire plaisir à leurs clients et à
leurs partenaires peuvent acheter des
places de différence entre piste mais le
public aussi alors qui peut venir quand
comment on fait si on est un particulier
on peut aller acheter sa place sur
internet très facilement via le site
internet des championnats d'europe c'est
3w championnat au pluriel europe piste
2016 point fr
on travaille avec ticket net donc on
peut acheter son billet à peu près
partout en fin de compte chez les
distributeurs de billetterie de
spectacles
on peut l'acheter aussi tout simplement
au guichet du vélodrome nationale je
précise ce point puisque les
saint-quentinois ont une remise
particulière sur le tarif
mais pour ça il faut qu'il justifie de
l'être avec un justification police ils
rêvent donc il faut qu'ils se rendre au
vélodrome nationale et là ils ont une
remise spéciale saint quentinois y en a
une pour les licenciés aussi avec des
béquilles de fête pour les enfants
démarrent à 10 euros et alors on est sur
des prix est très abordable pour un
spectacle qui chaque jour démarre vers
14 15 heures et se termine vers 22h donc
oui il ya de quoi avoir
j'espère voir exactement et les
entreprises les entreprises peuvent être
encore être partenaire de l'événement
peuvent aussi acheter des freins appelle
des packs de relations publiques
et là encore parce que nous sommes sur
le territoire de saint quentin nous
avons des tarifs spéciaux pour les
entreprises saint quentinois à ce jeu là
je lance un appel
n'hésitez pas à contacter les oui venez
parce que c'est vrai que ça c'est un
beau spectacle levé le groupe fait
d'ailleurs des ddd
des efforts faits sur leurs relations
publiques dont il ya beaucoup organisé
mi ner aussi aux jo de rome il ne vit
pas que pendant les grands événements ça
veut dire homme qui vit toute l'année
avec des abonnés qui est de faire de la
piste mais il ya du badminton ya de la
gym en fait il ya plein d'activités géré
par la société vélopolis qui gère le
vélodrome
et puis on peut organiser aussi un
séminaire d'entreprise sur place faire
des baptêmes de piste enfin il se passe
plein de choses
stéphane il faut que vous essayez ya eu
une remise de diplômes de l'université
au vélodrome laquelle je n'ai pas
assisté je n'ai pas été diplômés mais en
tout cas je sais que la fin ça a été un
succès considérable mais c'est un vieux
et c'est un lieu tout à fait
emblématique du territoire comme aux
éléments aujourd'hui un bon alors pour
les béotiens comme moi les des vélos de
piste c'est des vélos arrow fixe ou oui
les vélos de piste ce sont des vélos
avec un pignon fixe et s'enfonça ce qui
permet de faire des c en place c'est ça
qui permet de faire du surplace alors
pour les plus aguerris un non sens pour
moi ni pour moi d'avancer
cela dit c'est vrai c'est magnifique
quand il est absolument on a et on va
être notamment poursuite il me semble on
vous entend qui entérine manga ou ou
françois labrie s'est effectivement il
faut peut-être le premier à partir quoi
sert exactement alors les règlements
évolué ils ont moins de possibilités de
sur place mais ils en font toujours
c'est un vélo très léger on l'a dit
pignon fixe sans frein donc ça nécessite
effectivement un apprentissage
particulier il finissait pas de vitesse
n'ont pas de vitesse et il ya chez des
champions donc l'art du choix du plateau
du nombre de dents enfin paradis s'ils
font la vitesse de l'endurance donc ça
change
et puis il ya surtout une piste donc de
250 mètres de long lui m de large et
avec des virages inclinés à 44 degrés et
c'est là où
il faut savoir rouler sur une piste
c'est quand même extrêmement technique
extrêmement spectaculaires et des
erreurs en cham et alors il ya des liens
de passage d'ailleurs entre entre le
cyclisme de piste et le second d'une
route
quelqu'un comme cavendish non et oui
puis même moi je vous parle un français
qui est sur le tour en ce moment
bryan coquard coca et qui fait de la
piste qui fait la route enter et qui dit
lui-même que la piste lui apporte
beaucoup beaucoup de technique justement
et que dans dans ses performances dans
les sprints la piste lui apporter
beaucoup d'agilité sur le vélo très bien
donc
alors donc à partir du 19 octobre
jusqu'au 23 octobre au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mais n'hésitez
pas à réserver à ça avant oui parce
qu'un parce que les championnats du
monde on est à guichet fermé la
billetterie avait ouverte plus proche de
l'événement mais c'était parti très vite
là elle est ouverte dont je ne peux qu
un seul réservoir oui à lyon versailles
et acheter leurs places dès maintenant
parce qu'après ça va s'accélérer et il
ya 5000 places 5000 places par jour pas
une de plus clarence à 90
oui on ira donné tu es bien découvrir
parlons alors parlé de cyclisme sport
extrêmement populaire il ya eu l'euro de
football évidemment avec un très bon
comportement de la france
là aussi est ce que vous avez été frappé
les uns et les autres parlent
l'engouement au fond populaire le succès
populaire malgré voilà ddr2 peu
difficile sur d'autres plans quoi oui
mais justement c'est pour ça c'est que
je pense que
les français et la france avait besoin
de deux rires de crier d'être content
d'oublier effectivement les les pneus
brûlés de la cgt d'oublier les attentats
d'oublier plein de choses en avait on
avait besoin de ça donc c'est très bien
là il ya plus de gauche de droite il ya
plus
ouais c'est un peu le lieu commun de
dire ça mais tout le monde est content y
a vraiment commencé
comment m'expliquer ça c'est aux
phocéens et votre morineau échappe quand
même je les regardais pas sur le terrain
mais données et la fierté rejaillit sur
tout le monde
mais d'abord il ya une fierté énorme
parce qu'il ya eu ce combat contre
l'allemagne c'est vraiment un combat il
a ça faisait des années que que la
france ait pas battu l'allemagne plus
lésés en amour les allemands réalité
d'un mépris ne pas pas les joueurs mais
la presse allemande était d'un mépris la
veille du match en montrant même la
laddh la photo de louis de funès en
gendarme cruchot pour pour se moquer des
français en disant goodbye la défense
est un gruyère enfin ils ont été d'une
d'un mépris qui moi qui me rappelle le
mépris de juppé pour sarkozy par les
allemands il a même offert
voilà il a eu la cgt il a réussi à
l'éviter
oui c'était pas content à paris entre
nous non tu diras cgt et juppé alors que
tu parleras de l'euro de foot bravo la
cfa2 vous aviez prévu le bon
comportement de l'islande n'est ce pas
alors voyez que ça a déclenché des
sourires narquois de la part de certains
sur quant à mes pronostics et quant à
mon diagnostic n'était plus qu'un
premier or vous avez vu le comportement
de cette équipe a été extraordinaire non
seulement sur le plan sportif mais aussi
sur le plan comment dirais-je populaire
convivial et aidera donc voila vous vous
riez mois les images en charge du jeu
admiré des islandais est ce que j'ai
trouvé vraiment très très drôle c'était
là la façon dont le
ministre des affaires étrangères
islandais avait répondu à la question
comment sélectionne thon23 islandais il
était parti de 330000 islandais 165
mille femmes
je ne sais plus combien de moins de 18
ans ge j'ai vu neuf aveugle ses valises
au pied des falaises et cetera et puis
après c'était vraiment drôle sur la fin
une petite astérix une petite astérix et
l'entraîneur et suédois c'était juste 23
preneur cette veille n'était pas tombé
le président-élu pas encore investi mais
élu qui a tenu à s'asseoir parmi les
supporters islandais qui n'a pas qui n'a
pas siégé dans la tribune présidentielle
voilà moi j'ai bien aimé ça aussi c'est
sympathique mais c'est un petit peu
comme le maire de rambouillet ou de la
grèce n'est pas non plus il ya moins de
menaces qui pèsent sur le président
islandais que son président français on
peut comprendre un sommet on peut
comprendre que non mais je veux dire des
tas de gens ont dit oui au land de break
là bas n'ont presque plus tôt possible
en normal c'est sympathique mais assez
sympathique
justement on avait beaucoup hollande à
tous les matchs de l'équipe de france et
il pleuvait pas et ses pas et s'est
passé des choses comme un mille oui
alors il ya deux choses il ya à la fois
on voit toujours dans ces moments là il
ya un regain enfin les gens chantent la
marseillaise se lève on de la
marseillaise ils agitent les drapeaux
bleu blanc rouge
donc il ya un petit regain comme ça de
patriotisme et puis il ya toujours les
politiques qui espère comme un peu
chirac en 98 que ça leur sera utile
votre avis c'est l'effet bears house est
profond nous ça me paraît assez éphémère
enfin pour françois hollande
ça peut bénéficier quelques jours mais
je suis pas certaine que à la rentrée au
mois de septembre
les bruits pour rien mais voilà comme
nous tous non mais ce qui est vraiment
formidable dans cette dans cette coupe
d'europe c'est comment parler de ferveur
tout à l'heure c'est que les gens je
pense effectivement était extrêmement
fatigué de tous ces déchirements qu'on a
au travers de ces derniers mois
déchirements politiques des chameaux
sociaux les problématiques d'attentât et
que et qu'ils n'attendent qu'une chose
c'est de pouvoir avoir quelque chose de
gai joyeux et de faire un peu la fête et
sûrs d'eux avant cette annonce à la
popularité des enseignes qui ont gagné
mais c'est vrai que il ya peu
d'événements au fond un moment de sport
je ne sais pas si on a beaucoup d'autres
qui qui qui regroupe tout un peuple
s'il y avait un français qui gagne le
tour de france je pense qu'ils auraient
aussi la fierté nationale formidable et
de nom mais c'est extrêmement fédérateur
c'est pourquoi les métros fédérateur à
part le sport il ya la guerre et la
guerre oui à parts égales mais voilà il
a fallu l'intervention
c'est un métier jan chan non mais tu
réveilles mais je pense que enfin il ya
une menace comme le terreau il s'est
passé la même chose n'est pas la même
chose
il ya un parallèle parce que là c'est
une wii france allemagne à chaque fois
enfin je veux pas dire qu'on rejoue
14-18 et 39-45
oui j'en fait mal - oui on joue ces
vignes etc
enfin moi je me souviens très bien mes
arrière grands parents alors quand il y
avait des rencontres de foot entre la
france et l'allemagne l'enjeu les
casques à pointes et bord il y avait des
traces et multi désert et ses vignes
mais là c'est une sorte de c'est une
guerre qui bat qui va pas en principe
faire de victime que c'est pas une
guerre qui va qui va coûter cher il y
aura pas de mort à la fin c'est
peut-être là et ça peut même rapporter
des sous donc moi j'y vois un peu une
espèce de toujours une espèce de petit
réminiscences historique sur une forme
un peu comme ça de conflit depuis après
de requiem
quand on remporte la victoire et c'est
bon c'est quand même plus sympa de se
battre dans un stade qui bat vraiment
avec la guerre non vraiment les termes
dans lesquels on en parle rappellent
parfois ceux qu'on emploie pour pour
analyser un confrère me battre régis est
alors essentiel le sport comme unique
des émotions fortes d'un tendon qu'on
partage ses émotions et ce qui est
intéressant dans l'euro cette année par
rapport à l'attitude des joueurs de
l'islande par rapport au comportement
des supporters irlandais par rapport à
l'équipe de france de cette année on a
des joueurs plus humble plus collectif
qui se battent ensemble et qui donne des
émotions qui sont plus modestes ou
simplement il ya moins de problèmes et
et voilà les gens se retrouvent autour
de ça ces belles émotions simplement une
déclaration très sympa de djibril cissé
qui disait c'était début de semaine
avant le 7 victoires contre l'allemagne
qui dit mais en tout cas l'équipe de
france est extraordinaire parce que ils
se sont sortis de du passé et de ce
qu'on leur avait laissé après le but de
que de krishna
on leur a laissé un champ de ruines
et c'était sympa de sa part de dire ça
on a laissé une équipe enfin une
ambiance un truc complètement mortifère
et ça y est ils en sont sortis ils ont
ils ont regagné le le coeur du public
ils ont reconstruit une équipe et c'est
vrai que c'est assez sympa et une chose
alors sur laquelle on parle de danse des
représentants mais qui est là c'est vrai
c'est aussi la chance de deschamps ça
veut dire que je sais pas alors je ne
sais pas si mes nerfs présence de
benzema aurait changé les choses
en tout cas dans l'ambiance ou pas mais
en tout cas ils avaient plus que
sélectionné puisqu'il était pris dans
cette sphère de sextape
après il mais rami qui est pas très bon
et qui prend deux cartons jaunes ils
obligés de notre titi qui sélectionne
des il a en face des communique
quand ils match contre l'allemagne
l'équipe d'allemagne un peu diminué
parce qu'il est quand même pas mal de
blessés c'est vrai que je dis souvent
qu'il ait eu beaucoup de chance mais il
en a quoi il avait dû savoir-faire aussi
peut-être de la chance il ya du métier
moi à moi un certain point il me fait un
peu penser à aimé jacquet aussi oui dans
la discrétion dans la simplicité mais
techniciens avec la palmarès de joueur
plus important qu'un palmarès de joueur
plus important mais il construit
progressivement qui ça marche mais ça
barde il a de la chance mais enfin il me
la fille salon il a passé un cap il
détient un euro où tout le monde a eu de
la chance parce que je dirais les âmes
islandais de notre ami ont quand même eu
beaucoup de chance d'arriver jusque là
le pays de galles a eu de la chance
d'arriver et à des tas d'équipés eu la
chance donc doivent dire que la france
et de la chance nous le fassions de la
france deschamps c'est vrai que c'est
bon c'est une liaison three wheeler gfa
sa nouvelle chanson
il a tout réalisé dans sa carrière alors
d'où vous êtes vous êtes directeur
général de la fédération française de
cyclisme et vous êtes c'est un golfeur
c'est long non mais si excellent et il
est allé à l'open de france
absolument c'était un bel open de france
avec beaucoup de public ça faisait
plaisir à voir
oui un record de records d'affluence
ouais je pense que l'effet mcilroy a
quand même bien fonctionné beaucoup de
monde j'espère que c'est de bon augure
pour la ryder cup en 2018 alors c'est
l'avant avant dernier avant la 7e open
de france c'est l'avant dernier avant la
ryder un bel open déjà très beaux
aménagements un beau plateau de joueurs
ont sans justement que la ryder cup et
éclaire les cadors viennent repérer le
parti a très beau parcours d'ailleurs ça
aussi il faut le dire les équipes du
golf national ont fait un travail
merveilleux sur le parcours sur le
drainage du parcours doit oui on était
un peu notre niveau la dernière fois
avec pau leur vitrine juste avoir le
justement le directeur national juste
avant le ban de france et c'est vrai que
et l'ayant travail de drainage
absolument il a plu des et des quantités
d'eau incroyable et s'annonçant ne
perçoit pas du tout sur ce parcours je
propose de regarder un sujet justement
sur cette 100ème open de france et en
europe par la presse une surprise pour
cette 100e édition de l'open de france
tong chaï jeddi 46 ans remporte le
tournoi avec une carte de 68 soit 11
coups sous le par
le sportif devance l'italien francesco
molinari de quatre coups le golfeur
devient par la même occasion le premier
asiatique à remporter cette compétition
depuis 1971 armes spatiales week for me
et non oui mais je pense que ce week end
était vraiment spécial et c'était un
grand week-end pour moi c'est la plus
grande victoire de ma vie et remporter
cette coupe était vraiment fantastique
croyez moi je suis vraiment ravi de sa
c'est absolument parfait parti à deux
coups de la tête la superstar de cet
open de france rory mcilroy n'a pas pu
bousculer le thaïlandais dans la
dernière journée le 4e mondial signe une
carte de 71 pour terminer troisièmes à
cinq coups du leader
ça a été difficile de mettre vos prix du
beurre 10 les conditions n'étaient pas
excellentes pour le faire
tong chaï a joué de façon très
impressionnante et je pense que je
n'avais aucune chance de gagner les
derniers coups n'étaient pas trop mal oh
je pense que je suis dans la bonne
direction
du côté des français julien quesne et
mathieu decottignies lafon terminé 16e
ex-aequo et grégory bourdy a lui fini
25e
le chouchou du public français victor
dubuisson terminant 66e et dernière
position de l'open de france avec une
carte de plus 17
son plus mauvais score en huit éditions
au golf national
alors là aussi on attend un français
victor dubuisson peut pas bien qu'il ait
fait qui est le premier français le
premier joueur français
et un score dans fait c'était pas une
bonne année pour victor dubuisson mais
c'est pas grave alors on attend un
français on a quand même eu que ce soit
thomas levet et jean van hamme et si ces
dernières années d ici la fin novembre à
jouer tsonga est un beau vainqueur
franchement mcilroy n va loin il ya un
niveau magnifique bel événement beau
tournoi et vous avez essayé de jouer
juste après alors moi j'ai eu la chance
de jouer le parcours juste après sa
réouverture directement après les
travaux juste après qu'il ait beaucoup
plus effectivement on ne pouvait pas se
douter sur le fairway sur les greens qui
défendait autant d'eau donc voilà une
fois encore les travaux de drainage
fonctionne merveilleusement bien on est
parfaitement prêt pour la ryder cup 2018
les autres propositions extrêmement
amusant à suivre c'est pareil fait
partie des sports on peut être
relativement près des des sportifs de
haut niveau
on les voit on peut les suivre sur toute
une partie changé de parti parce qu'elle
fait partie des des choses vraiment
amusante à suivre même si on n'y connaît
pas grand chose ils me connaissent ils
voient la star c'est bien de très beaux
endroits aussi très agréable à voir
moi j'ai souvenir d'avoir labour est en
partie le golf royale de meknès où
j'étais invité dans des conditions très
privilégié et on a proposé une leçon une
première leçon de golf et donc ça a été
ça a été le labour
le carnage c'était la première et la
dernière assemblée ray et depuis je suis
interdit de séjour au maroc
non parce que on m'expliquait que le
geste du golfeur était naturel je suis à
quoi j'ai répondu qu'il était assez rare
quand même que j'accomplisse
naturellement ce type de geste et il a
dû être d'autant moins naturel chez moi
que ceci n'explique pas cela mais que
j'ai eu quelques difficultés de deux
hernies discales ah oui oui dans la
suite donc ça me laissera un souvenir
impérissable sur sas aussi naturel que
ça va c'est pareil
avant tout l'histoire les coaches les
professeurs vous disent toujours mais
c'est un geste naturel sur le bim
champions voilà sûr c'est que savard est
toujours d'une simplicité et d'une
fluidité extraordinaire chez les autres
si j'ai essayé comme celle indien voilà
oui j'ai essayé une fois et j'ai pu
voilà j'ai réfléchi de google ne séduit
pas tout le monde apparemment je sais
pas si vous avez vu les déclarations du
nouvel entraîneur du psg qui a déjà
balancé une un scud envers son
prédécesseur laurent blanc vous me posez
la question là ce que vous êtes un
fervent amateur de golf de notre façon
un entraîneur de foot qui joue gauche
c'est un mauvais entraîneur il sait ce
qu'il s'occupe pas assez de son équipe
donc donc c'est nul donc moi je ne joue
pas au golf et je n'ai pas le temps de
jeu et c'est pour cela se passe ouais
voilà qui va se faire des ennemis du
côté de la france dit non j'aime bien le
gag mais moi c'est le foot
voilà c'est un bon y est un bon
entraîneur va pas attendre google
c'est vrai que il ya énormément de deux
footballeurs qui jouent regret qui joue
très bien d'ailleurs boghossian et votre
- enfin web impressions et louis ii 0 -
et notamment l'emballage a pas que lui
ginola
voilà j'ai très bien mais c'est vrai
quoi jouer et c'est vrai que d'après non
il a raison de dire qu'il se consacrait
la pluie l'a plutôt intérêt du berger je
verrai jamais d'aller s'amuser sur les
terrains de golf mais je pense que pour
la concentration ça c'est ce qu'ils
disent dès hier tosato des champions
beaucoup de champions de sports four du
golfe et je crois que pour la
concentration c'est beaucoup de
champions de sports front du gauche
parce que c'est bon pour la
concentration à la base ils ont fait
aussi parce que ça fait partie des rares
sports que leurs agents leurs assureurs
lors interdit pas de faire confie t il
ce rendu compte effectivement que c'est
un sport de concentration un sport de
précision
et c'est pour ça que tous les tous les
sportifs de haut niveau particulièrement
avec les sports de balle
sont vides bon golf parce qu'ils ont
cette sensation ils ont ce feeling avec
la balle et il progresse très vite après
soit un endroit autre sens sur le sport
où on passe alors une actualité plus tôt
on peut peut-être revenir là sur un
événement qui a été un peu triste qui
était la mort de michel rocard
grande figure de la vie politique des
grandes figures aussi des yvelines
puisque il a été il a été élu député
contre le premier ministre de l'époque
c'était monsieur maurice couve de
murville dans une élection partielle si
je me souviens bien
et puis il a été maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine
je propose de voir un sujet avec des
réactions sur la mort de michel rocard
on en parle tout de suite après il a
bien parlé
un parler vrai moi c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours plu et qui me manque
aujourd'hui important de savoir dire les
choses et de prendre des décisions et
surtout de savoir s'engager malgré ce
que l'on peut attendre en retour
il avait été maire et ensuite il a été
député il a été mis en une nuit
sénateurs je veux dire c'est quelqu'un
qui a eu un parcours politique que d'une
expérience incroyable et qui est
véritablement je crois travailler pour
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'intérêt
général dans les vignes de plus grande
partie des militants ont été re car bien
de soit de manière directe ou indirecte
c'est une fédération qui était et
d'avoir rocardienne qui s'est construit
autour aussi ce personnage tout à fait
particulier politiquement quitté michel
rocard et donc oui vous interrogez
n'importe quel militant il leur a
toujours des anecdotes vous raconter sur
les campagnes qu'il a mené avec michel
ou sur des parcours qu'ils ont eu en
commun donc ces personnalités
actuellement marquante pour nous c'est
une grande tristesse parce que pour moi
c'est peut-être un ami et un patron
j'ai commencé mon apprentissage
politique avec lui au psu c'est un homme
d'une telle intelligence d'une telle
réflexion
j'aimais beaucoup son esprit son esprit
créatif et enthousiaste en même temps ce
qui manque beaucoup
il me semble aux nouvelles générations
en politique c'est plutôt un homme
simple sincère constructif constructif
c'était pas du tout un démolisseur comme
on l marxiste qui veut il faut détruire
l'entreprise le chef d'entreprise le
droit du travail ça nous a tous fait
l'entreprise ça doit le mettre en danger
en permanence
michel aulas est le premier homme d'état
socialiste qui a osé poser cette
question il s'est même fâché avec
françois mitterrand souvenez-vous parce
qu'il ne voulait pas il voulait
justement que le parti socialiste ne
gardent cet axe comme tous les partis
socialistes bien sûr européen de couper
avec cette vision très archaïque de
l'économie
voilà alors un hommage de tous les bords
de la politique puisque on a vu des gens
de gauche évidemment qui a travaillé
avec lui comme catherine tasca des gens
de l'autre bord de droit tous et qui lui
rendent hommage
c'est vrai qu'il ya une sorte
d'unanimité alors est ce que c'est la
mort qui veut ça
oui oui c'est d'abord parce que il ya
quand même une chose à part avec michel
rocard je crois que c'est juste on a dit
côté gauche il est dans une filiation
très proche de main des spu peut-être un
peu et jaurès de cette gauche réaliste
il fait partie c'est vrai que je crois
que je sais plus qui écrivait sa dent au
cours de la semaine de deux de ses de
ses élus de ces hommes politiques qui
sont appréciés par les gens qui n'aiment
pas la politique que la politique
révulse peut-être parce que je crois
qu'il avait une éthique une éthique de
gouvernement sans avoir une éthique
électoralistes voilà les politistes
disait il ya 2 il ya deux façons de
concevoir les choses la première c'est
pour se faire élire donc c'est les
promesses contient généralement déjà de
manière assez rare et puis l'autre c'est
vraiment les mains dans le cambouis et
l'action et ses deux éthiques sont en
réalité un concile le problème c'est que
parfois certains élus conservent au
gouvernement leur éthique d'élections
beaucoup et que peu de candidats ont une
éthique de gouvernement avant d'être élu
michel rocard faisait justement partie
de ces de ces gens à me parler vrai mais
le parler vrai c'est aussi parler
compliqué et par les complexes
je pense que c'était l'un des rares
hommes politiques qui ne n'avais pas sur
beaucoup de choses un discours simpliste
et qui ne donnaient pas le sentiment de
manipuler ou de se moquer un peu du
monde comme le font quand même pas mal
de candidats des élections et d'élus et
il y avait aussi une exigence morale je
crois que c'est ce qui le rapproche
aussi beaucoup de 2
demain dès l'ouest et puis de jaurès
avec un talent oratoire que peut-être il
y avait moins par rapport à jaurès
notamment mais il y avait une exigence
morale qui qui est assez rare je dis pas
que tous ont pourri où tous sont
malhonnêtes mais il y avait là une
exigence morale très forte très
fortement ancrée et donc à voir
aujourd'hui le concert de louanges dont
il est l'objet
oui la mort approche la mort feder mais
c'est quand même parfois un peu indécent
surtout lorsque ces louanges viennent
essentiellement de la part de membres du
parti socialiste oui vous pour sa
carrière n'ont quand même pas mal à la
faire décrocher lui faire des sales
coups et il faut pas oublier l'accès au
fond on y mitterrand ce qui est vrai
qu'ils étaient des rapports compliqués
avec mitterrand mais y ait eu beaucoup
de parti socialiste je ne m'abuse ne
cesse que de le renverser quand les
socialistes
beaucoup de gens du parti socialiste on
était chez ses ennemis longtemps pêché
deux je pense que présenter à la
présidence enfin je pense que là il
traduit bien ce qu'on dit souvent aux
politiques vos adversaires sont devant
vous mais vos ennemis sont derrière vous
plante
ah oui mais j'étais oui ça m'a beaucoup
touché 7 ce décès parce que cet homme
effectivement en termes de morale
d'éthique de paroles vraies 2
discours et puis de vision je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui avait une vraie
vision sur une nouvelle gauche sur cette
fameuse deuxième gauche qu'il a essayé
de lancer avec peut-être que valls et
macro ont quelque part soit un peu les
héritiers de michel rocard sévère mais
la dernière interview qu'elle a donnée
au point oui oui mais bon il considérait
valls est un peu comme ma pas son fils
mais un peu comme quelqu'un qui était
très proche
enfin très proche de lui donc même si
peut-être sévère un certain on aurait
dit qu'il n'avait pas lui qui était un
socialiste internationaliste et disait
qu'il avait pas cette dimension
internationale afin de vision
oui dis donc donc voilà donc je pense
que mais non j'ai trouvé que cette cette
unanimité un peu bizarre aussi sur sur
le spectre politique qui s'en dit que je
préférais de la droite
on a souvent reproché à m donc ça
s'explique aussi d'une certaine façon
oui et c'est je pense qu'il avait
peut-être effectivement plus d'amitié à
droite qu'à gauche où il avait quand
même beaucoup d'ennemis pas qu'il agit
comme un vrai venu temps doux et enfin
j'étais il ya passé sa vie quoi oui mais
il avait une ouverture économique qui
n'est peut-être pas une grande partie de
politique de gauche donc ce qui fait
expliqué effectivement cette réaction à
droite moi je retiens de michel rocard
que c'était un européen convaincu
ça c'est important et quelques son décès
quelques jours après le brésil
oui la france est vrai il savait que
c'était quelqu'un qui parlait de
l'europe y en a peu à peu dans la vie
politique à leur femme mais oui monsieur
un peu perplexe parce que je suis pas le
maître notre nom jusqu'au bout
il ya deux sauts d'entre eux d'abord
tout le monde semble l'aimer parce qu'on
aime aussi un peu les losers parce que
c'est quand même un peu un loser en
politique parce qu'il n'a pas réussi à
être président et où contrairement à ce
que beaucoup de gens disent il aurait
rêvé de ça il a essayé de se présenter
c'est mitterand qui lui a toujours coupé
l'herbe sous le pied donc c'est quand
même là il ya un côté loser donc c'est
pour ça que maintenant tu sois cet homme
qui s'est présenté il n'a pas réussi
grand chose en fait que politiquement a
à ses supérieurs et trois ans quand même
il est à matignon soit pas l'à-peu-près
les meilleures années c'est moins d'un
an au gouvernement on en parle encore de
nom oui mais alors jean charles a
peut-être raison parce qu'on aime aussi
les gens qui ont regardé de l'or est
très apprécié simone weill simone veil
dans toute l'europe les sondages sont
arrivés à pas grand chose enfin tout cas
pas peint ou des marques on les trouve
merveilleux ça c'est une chose
et puis l'autre chose qui me maternelle
véritablement je ne comprends pas c'est
là j'allais dire la prétention son
testament dire que j'étais smith
époustouflé que rocard qu'il était
effectivement vous dites tous le parler
vrai en dribbles etc
et là il est là en organisant des
funérailles mais je veux dire de gaulle
c'était incroyable talent va baisser
il faut aller aux invalides il faut que
ce soit le président de la république il
faut que ça soit ceux ci après faudra
qu'il ya un truc à tel endroit faudrait
qu'ils aient un truc au ps
enfin c'est un enterrement de monarque
les essais un de pharaon
c'est de cette incroyable convenons
glisse tout ça mais non mais on a trouvé
un nouvel attentat de la musique c'est
quand même pas mal
aucun aucun n'aurait aucun homme
politique jusqu'à présent n'a osé un
truc pareil voilà il ya pas mort je
reviens je reviens je reviens sur le
fond parce que c'est un peu intéressant
avec les débats qu'on a eues aujourd'hui
sa grande thèse était en effet qu' il
fallait pas tout attendre de l'état et
et qu' il fallait que la société farc et
les débours naissent dans la société que
la négociation soit plus forte presque
la loi etc
on voit bien que on est encore dans ces
débats là aujourd'hui à la loi comrie
enfin c'était un des indés
des débats qui a fait que là qu'est la
loi en russie était aussi difficile à
adopter non c'est clair donc gilles est
vraiment dans le fam pas lui mais enfin
macron et dense est dans cette lignée là
de faire prévaloir les négociations
d'entreprise de
c'est très français de quoi attirer tout
à fait prêts à croire et à souhaiter que
que macron soit dans la droite ligne de
d'euros car ça me plairait beaucoup
mais j'ai l'impression que ça va ça va
en effrayer beaucoup et que tout le
monde va se réécrire
mais jamais les gens ne supporteront pas
l'idée que macron puisse être un
héritier quelque part de rocard ce que
tout à fait dommage mais je crois pas du
tout parce que les jeux parce que les
aider les gens et surtout à gauche je ne
ne supporte pas macron et que voilà ils
ont récupéré rocard c'est pas pour
récupérer macron dans le filet ça je
pense que à la réserve près que michel
rocard était face définissait comme
étant authentiquement de gauche
le ni droite ni gauche ou la droite et
gauche de macron été totalement non
regarde bien du point de vue politique
en tout cas et puis c'est vrai que
rocard était quand même un enfant d'une
gauche très militante de deux ans mai 68
rocard était le poing levé dans les
manifestations le candidat c'était le
candidat alors il a fait 3 il a fait 300
enfants
nous donnons sépare proches tu as peur
tu marches c'est quand même pas non plus
c'est quelque chose ce n'est pas sa
politique vis à vis de requins c'était
la politique il est là passer des
soirées il était inspecteur déchets
l'inspecteur général des finances comme
ailleurs mais non mais c'est vrai mais
enfin bon il a passé beaucoup de
militantisme quand même je suis sereine
un autre avenir un maquereau que celui
de requins par an c'est mal à venir est
peut-être le plus intéressant parce qu'
on cherche toujours à raccrocher au
passé dont qui est l'héritier qu'il
désigne l'endroit
et si on parlait de demain de parler de
dire est qu'on se demande ce qu'on va
faire c'est vrai on a besoin mais ça
fait partie un peu voilà c'est très
frais et figure même si tu es l'air
comme s'appellent on cherche à se
raccrocher parce que peut-être parce
qu'on sait pas très bien de quoi demain
sera fait peut-être un pas très bien à
quoi dire c'est un vrai courant
politique quand même kiki leur organisme
ou enfin le regard de cette gauche là en
tout cas rocard a pas été l'inventeur de
cela mais cette gauche-là à l'existant
gros depuis le depuis le milieu du 19e
siècle voulait alors elle se traduit
l'esprit mais de manière différente
bienvenus il ya un vrai courant quand
même est minoritaire
c'est un ruisseau à votre observation
je pense aussi que si on se raccroche
des éléments du passé c'est qu'on a pas
grand monde qui peut nous faire rêver
sur l'avenir aussi aujourd'hui donc on
va chercher aussi de défauts mais je
n'ai pas rêvé dans votre chat visuel
unique et des idées qui nous plaisait
mais on n'a pas besoin de me provisions
c'est le fun labs alors bien sûr en ciel
je parle simplement de quelqu'un qui
nous disent voilà la société telle que
moi j'aimerais qu'elle soit et je vous
propose une société comme ça et voilà le
programme que je déroule pour arriver à
cette société là aujourd'hui on nous dit
voilà un programme et on la finalité
vers quelle société on ne sait pas mais
on s'aperçoit finalement que les gens
apparemment les plus humbles sont
finalement les plus sûrs d'eux elle est
par exemple
hulot qui ne se présente pas en disant
je n'ai pas envie d'être l'homme
providentiel mais qui pensaient que une
eau et l homme providentiel
bojan non mais oh beaucoup de jos et
écologie
débattue avant les écologistes font de
2,6 et beaucoup merci mes 14 ans des
farces et beaucoup mélenchon avait 14 il
a fini à combien bon je sais faire non
c'est passé à 14 on n'est pas un homme
providentiel
désolé alors qui se présente ou pas peu
me chaut mais en attendant nous c'est ce
que ce qui est respectable c'est à dire
j'ai pas envie ou je n'y arriverai pas
voilà c'est tout je ne suis pas un peu
ce fut un peu une vierge cicr interrogé
sur ce raid sur le fait de savoir s'il
avait là c'est de la structure pour
devenir des espaces non je veux que
jean-charles utilise le verbe shalwar et
je l'en félicite
c'est chevènement qui avait participé à
une autorisation d'ouverture sont
vainement un kurde est l'ennemi juré de
recaptcha juste avant de vous il la
deuxième gauche c'est pas lui continue
parler de la deuxième gauche qui disent
et la social démocratie
ça s'appelle à l'international martial
démocratie sauf que les y aurait
d'ailleurs dans son discours
hollande a su récupérer quand même tout
oui bon soin et de grappiller odin qu'il
le peut mais la social démocratie
aujourd'hui à l'international il n'en
reste plus vraiment grand chose
les sociaux démocrates allemands sont
constitués souvent en exemple sont pas
franchement en bonne position
la social démocratie britannique c'est
plus ça depuis blair la social
démocratie des pays d'europe du nord
aussi la chance est avec des partis
populistes très fort enfin bon ça va pas
très fort de ce point de vue là on va on
va peut-être terminée avec un délai je
ne sais pas ce que vous espérez l'heure
de la rentrée prochaine
parce que voyez vous ça va être une
année évidemment très politique
puisqu'il va y aura les primaires à
droite à gauche les élections
présidentielles comment vous voyez cette
rentrée je rêve je rêve de l'abandon des
primes et à droite comme à gauche parce
que vraiment j mais plus ça va plus on
s'aperçoit que c'est c'est la fin de
tout des primaires dire qu' aucun
candidat ne surnage naturellement aucun
candidat n'arrive à diriger son parti
correctement c'est terrifiant c'est à
dire c'est la fin vraiment d'un monde
politique et voilà qui est qui qui
surnage je suis de nature optimiste je
disais justement si les parties
s'écroule et c'est peut-être la chance
de gens comme maquereau ou un autre
jeune en tout cas pour l'instant on voit
que macron qui a l'air de ne peut
peut-être pouvoir s'en sortir sans parti
politique derrière lui jusqu'à présent
c'est ça paraît impossible en france de
ne pas avoir de parti derrière soi
peut-être que lui sera le premier à
réussir quelque chose
mais franchement tu sais ces batailles
picrocholines a pesé mais c'est ridicule
et c'est déprimant réguler les primaires
c'est un trompe l'oeil parce que ça
remplace la crise de fin ça a été fait
parce que les parties étaient en crise
mais en fait ça permet aux parties de
reprendre la main sur les élections sur
ces élections-là d'externalisation d'une
fonction qui normalement est propre un
parti politique un parti pris que ça
sert d'abord à produire des candidats et
là c'est le signe d'une très grande
faiblesse des partis politiques en
france
et puis je suis entièrement d'accord
avec votre analyse
ça a un effet un effet terrible
d'enfermement du débat politique à
l'intérieur
deux parties entre personnes alors dont
on manque on n'en connaît pas un tiers à
peu près sur l'ensemble tout de tous les
candidats déclarés et une espèce d'effet
de stérilisation du débat politique y
compris dans les enceintes type
assemblée nationale où on voit que
maintenant je veux les débats qui ont eu
lieu à propos de la loi travail était
digne de débat primaires à gauche où la
gauche est resté entre elles les députés
de droite ont d'ailleurs eu raison de
sortir à cet instant-là stratégiquement
c'était très c'était très bien vu et à
droite c'est la même chose il est
question simplement de débat interne au
parti on externalise une fonction qui
revient un parti ces signes de faiblesse
et puis ces signes d'une espèce d'atonie
d'atomisation du débat politique
national
c'est très malsain et en même temps
grâce aux primaires les parties
reprennent la main sur ces leur
réalisation par la fenêtre parce que
c'est la politique sans des partis pour
l'instant on sait qu'on sait pas comment
ça marche on n'a pas où on n'a pas
trouvé mieux
alors les parties sont décriés mais
c'est pour l'instant en dispensant sauf
que là on a on a une telle explosion des
partis politiques en france et qui
s'érode qui n'ont plus que plus rien à
dire qu'ils sont en train de se déchirer
je veux dire la gauche cesser
complètement pathétique et du coup on a
une montée des populismes qui est quand
même extrêmement inquiétante enfin moi
je trouve qui est très inquiétante
partout en europe 1 que l'on voit la
montée du populisme en angleterre avec
le vrai qu site ce qui est quand même là
aussi un effort du populisme brio
certain que ce soit en autriche que ce
soit en allemagne aussi que ce soit en
suède en france en espagne on voit que
partout où les politiques sont faibles
et où partout où ça se déchire on a une
montée des populismes très forte et moi
ce que j'espère pour pour l'après l'itc
que c'est nos hommes politiques ce
retrait d'un peu et effectivement je
pense que les primaires moi je suis
assez contresigne mais se reprennent un
peu et qu'on arrive à juguler ce
phénomène qui malachie est inquiétant en
europe la trouvais un peu la fin de
l'émission pour annoncer cette
information à nos courtiers dont vous
êtes candidat aux primaires surtout pas
justement pour revenir pour revenir à
vous c'est quoi le directeur général
derrière ces dalles une fédération il ya
un président qui est élu absolument il
ya un président qui est élu et d'autres
élus qui composent un bureau exécutif on
a un conseil fédéral vous gérez un petit
peu comme commun et à nos hommes
politiques qui sont là qui sont des
hommes d'abord passionnés investis qui
donnent leur temps ce sont des bénévoles
c'est important de le rappeler qu'ils
sont a finalement pour tracer les
grandes lignes de la des choix fédéraux
de la monique sportive il faut pas
oublier qu'on agit sur délégation
ministérielle donc c'est important dans
la gestion la responsabilité de la
gestion du développement de notre sport
de nos disciplines en france et puis
derrière eux il ya une équipe tout
simplement
que j'encadre mais avec aussi une équipe
encadrée par le directeur technique
national sur l'aspect plus sportif
et puis on est une entreprise comme les
autres on a un service comptable au
service juridique un service
communication un service marketing une
partie dédiée à toutes là l'organisation
événementielle justement de nos
différents championnats de france coupe
de france dans nos disciplines parce
qu'on a la route on à la piste le vtt le
cyclo cross
mais ça le bmx donc voilà il ya beaucoup
de choses donc c'est tout une structure
d'une un peu plus de 40 salariés il faut
organiser tout ça et c'est mon rôle
celui de chef d'orchestre tout
simplement et votre formation
non j'étais pas dans le cyclisme avant
mais j'ai toujours travaillé dans le
monde du sport et ma formation elle est
une formation assez classique finalement
en école de commerce à la base
et puis au début un hasard et qui
devient un choix par passion derrière
passion du sport donc de d'accompagner
la gestion l'organisation et le
développement du sport en france avec
des fédérations avec des clubs avec
parfois des entités privées
donc voilà le sport toujours oui oui oui
je suis sportif alors je tension mais je
suppose un sportif professionnel
on nous demande souvent dans l'univers
sportif fédéral alors vous mais vous ne
vous a été champion on organise le sco
mhr le score champions et ils font ça
beaucoup mieux que nous vivons mais le
sport le sport que vous aviez pris mais
on fait un métier formidable je reviens
ce que je disais on organise l'événement
on communique des émotions aux gens et
c'est fédérateur et c'est formidable
parce qu'il ya en général le public nous
revient donc rappelant du 19 au 23
octobre exactement au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste
voila voila je m'entraîne bien perdre de
steam sur piste en octobre donc nous
pour la rentrée ce qu'on veut c'est
plein de points de monde ici et je
précise ce ne sera pas ici mais que nous
aurons à nice du 14 au 18 septembre les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
route à haute voix là et on enchaîne fin
octobre avec les championnats d'europe
de cyclo cross en bretagne à pontchâteau
donc
deux mois trois championnats d'europe et
les olympiques les jeux olympiques
d'abord ya rio qui arrive et ouais hein
qui est là et on attend évidemment nous
athlètes on est présent dans quatre
disciplines la piste le bmx le vtt et la
route et surtout on est en train de
travailler très activement avec le
comité de candidature pour paris 2024 et
saint-quentin je l'espère sera une terre
de l'impie sme avec le cyclisme et avec
le golfe voilà un cd de ces deux sports
qui seront représentés si si paris
galles et j'ai envie de dire quand paris
pour s'emparer voilà et on parle de
l'euro tout à l'heure c'est vrai que un
moment au début de l'euro peut-être
thévard y avait un peu de scepticisme
sur le fait de dire que ça va porter
atteinte à la candidature aux jeux
olympiques finalement peut-être que ça
va appuyer cette oui je pense pas du
tout que ça porte atteinte au contraire
on démontre dans le cadre de la
candidature notre savoir faire en
matière d'organisation mais il ya
évidemment les grèves qui faisait que
c'est dans le premier pays organisateur
plus ou moins systématique on utilise un
événement mais voilà on n'est pas les
seuls
non on n'est pas les seuls et puis si je
passe on va dire que c'est de bonne
guerre jean salvan terminée
ban devant ce conseil de lecture pour
l'été de ses deux bras peut lui offrir
il ya plus ou moins chef-d'oeuvre non
non ça n'a pas brillé mais je vois là
rochois mouchoirs c'est un petrowski un
peu la crise 7 à mr c'est un don camillo
moderne en fait c'est un prêtre
exorciste qui est pas du tout c'est pas
du tout un livre anticlérical c'est un
personnage vraiment amusant qui est oui
ray trek est très porté sur le titre est
pas très portés sur le sexe faible
ils sont à ranger un petit peu avec avec
son patron avec le créateur c'est très
drôle c'est vraiment une langue très
verte c'est à mi-chemin entre frédéric
dard et puis nadine monfils que la
gentillesse de faire la préface et qui
est l'auteur de mémé cornemuse phoques
est vraiment donc c'est très drôle voilà
merci beaucoup je m'appelle requiem est
jeté merci beaucoup
je veux passer de dec merci pour coup à
marnoz courtier donc bon au revoir on en
reparlera peut-être aller on a le temps
d'en parler mais enfin en tout cas déjà
vous pouvez réserver vos places
merci beaucoup à florence père cadets
merci beaucoup stéphane minson
qu'est ce que cous jean charles lajoie
n'diaye bonnes bonnes vacances donc l on
se retrouve
je pense au mois de septembre si tout va
bien